today on stick to football we have the
best offensive tackle in the draft
Jedrek wills from Alabama gonna hop on
with us we also have our team big boards
and we're gonna start it off with our
three favorite teams Niners Chiefs and
Jets your draft on draft questions and
guys we are gonna touch on a little bit
of news there's not a whole lot but a
little but to start this off our good
friends the bleacher report be our
gridiron and be our bedding are doing a
greatest of all time Madden sim fellas
and as the Niners fan on the show I just
want to say we will kick all your asses
I mean I'm not going to debate it for
much yeah I know that that's not gonna
be a thing but I think the Steelers
probably gonna give everybody a run for
their money with that defense like I
mean all those linebackers that they've
had for forever Terry Bradshaw probably
playing quarterback if he can beat out
Kordell Stewart again Ben maybe maybe
yeah I'm kind of curious when we tap
into these ratings and who makes the cut
when you have something really close I
would go with the Dallas Cowboys if I
had to argue with Matt here even saying
that I'm still pretty confident the
Niners are gonna be really really good
now Matt here's my question for you with
Steve Young's mobility would you rather
have him be your madden quarterback than
Joe Montana well I would rather have
Steve Young over Joe Montana as my rule
a lot of people don't know that about me
cuz I am a huge Montana fan Melo can
back me up on this I'm a I'm a Steve
young guy like and and was when it was
controversial you know like who should
be starting I was a Steve Young guy I'm
just a little bit too young to have seen
the great Joe Montana days I've gone
back and watched him obviously but yeah
I think you have to take Steve Young
here's the thing I just want to say this
and I don't know if our friends he'd be
our gridiron are gonna listen to me or
not I do not want Deion on the Niners
team he like played there for one year
don't want it and he's a falcon he
should you're a [ __ ] like he's not a
Niner he's not a cowboy oh boy he's a
falcon though I think you're right but I
I think they'll put him on the Cowboys
team just a mess with I think so too
yeah what are they gonna do duplicates
that's what I was gonna say like how are
you
to do that with so many players that
were good but I have played on multiple
teams I think you're gonna have to put
duplicate well I am excited to see the
rosters this is gonna come out Friday so
as you're listening to this you can hop
on instagram twitter and see what's
going down but it's the BR Madden goat
sim greatest of all time sim and I don't
know if we're actually taking real money
bets on this bit of so I'm I'm anxious
to see that line on the 49ers because I
they have to be the favorite I think
they're yeah maybe we can get it going
between us and the stickies if they want
to get involved you know maybe throw
down some bets I know they're gonna be
doing some kind of lines when they do
the twitch stream so if you need your
betting fix and you haven't seen the
draft bits yet which this show will
definitely get to at some point that's
another way to get involved and wait and
you know flushing your money away
exactly yeah it's giving us your money
alright Adam Schefter
has been Adams the league guy you know
he's always you know this is just the
news and I'm gonna stay out of it he
actually pushed back against the NFL a
little bit ESPN's national insider the
the NFL is saying hey the draft is
happening April 23rd it will be a three
day event and you can like it or you can
leave it shefter reported with Dianna
Rossini
that many general managers are pushing
back against us they're saying the draft
should not happen in late April there's
a million reasons why not and but the
league is saying no we're doing it and
it's gonna be awesome and it's gonna be
virtual we're gonna have cameras in
prospect houses and cameras and prospect
for cheap facilities i guys i think the
draft should not happen April 23rd and I
know a lot of people are gonna have mad
at me be like no we need it we need the
draft to happen we don't need it to
happen yet there's no rush to get this
thing done you're not gonna have Ricky
camp you're not gonna vote EAS there
should not be a rush I was telling Melo
on the way in to record today I was
talking to director of player personnel
for a team and he said hey man how are
we supposed to execute trades when you
can't like normally your owner your head
coach your general manager your whole
scouting staff they're sitting in a room
and they execute the draft plan if you
Connor the Jets you can't go to the team
facility right now
now you're shut down absolutely shut
down it's a great point in Kansas City
they do have a 30-day shutdown order
right now in place but what if the chief
you go on their team facility to execute
the draft plan and the Giants and Jets
and eagles can't that's a competitive
advantage 100 ohms that can all come
together and so I know I I know a lot of
people are gonna get upset and say hey
the draft needs to happen we need this
content that content May 15th is not
gonna be any different than it is April
23rd except for maybe there's more of a
competitive balance MOA what do you
think about this whole seven-day draft
idea that shefter floated out there
though I kind of give teams time to
recoup and figure I like the idea that
shefter is putting out there I don't
understand why the NFL isn't coming out
and announcing more plans for the draft
instead they just keep saying
everything's gonna be the same
everything's fine everything's normal
we don't know what the hell that looks
like as fans as people that cover the
draft we don't know we don't know if you
know we're gonna have cameras in each
war room we don't know how many people
are gonna be in the room so I like what
chef ders doing and what he's kind of
pitching here with a seven-day draft I
don't know about seven days but I do
like to mixing it up and put it in on
prime time starting with around 1:00
maybe start on like a Monday night or
whatever you want to do with that make
it prime time and then everybody on
Tuesday has something to talk about all
these radio guys all these weird podcast
guys who are probably in some weird
brick wall basement they have something
to talk about the next day then we go we
do round two the next day round three
and then maybe that day three draft we
break it up we can probably do that all
in one day but I like it I think gives
teams extra time like you were talking
about it's gonna be very difficult to
execute trades usually you have a guy on
the phone that's calling but if you're
only allowed six people ten people in a
room the first guy goes probably the
dude on the phone that you want your
Scouts to energy in you want your owner
in there so like who's making the cut
you know I don't know so what shefter is
doing I think it's a good start
of changing the draft it's not going to
look the same there's no way it can be
the same so why not toy with it why not
give everybody something to tune into
for five nights instead of two or three
exactly I think it opens the
conversation for maybe we should
experiment here it's something I had
thrown out there on Twitter was
especially with this giraffe class
there's so much fantasy impact because
of the wide receivers and running backs
where maybe you do night one is round
one as always night two is round
and then night three's rounds three and
four and then you could have rounds five
and seven as the final day because I
think there's enough where that third
night of rounds three and four people
would still be really really into it and
then you have the classic last day
rounds five to seven you know the
attention is definitely gonna Teeter off
now I am curious
guys this is gigantic this year for the
giraffe because there is no baseball
going on there is no NHL there is no MBA
right the draft has a chance to really
take in all of the eyes that potentially
can and I well I agree with you Matt the
competitive advantages of problem teams
are not happy about this there are all
kinds of different hurdles I mean we're
going in on a very smaller scale but as
media analysts we're gonna go through it
too as we continue to do this show from
home and figure out how we're gonna
continue to cover the draft I think when
you look at it the NFL has been very
stubborn into laying their season they
didn't delay free agency which has
caused hurdle for some players out there
still and they're not gonna delay the
draft because this is an advantage for
them it might sound a little sick but
it's a chance for them to capitalize in
a way I think we all know the NFL well
enough to confidently say that is at
play here they want all eyes on the NFL
Draft they're already trying to make the
draft a huge event by putting it in
primetime doing these fan events
obviously the fan event can't happen
this year but like you just said Connor
every sports fan escameca
well the drafts on ESPN and NFL Network
and Bleacher Report's app maybe I'll
check that out it is a huge opportunity
from a growth perspective to get more
eyes on it and it is it's like it's
almost a you know a little morbid to
talk about that but I definitely think
it is at play and it is it's uncharted
territory of how this is going to play
out and how it will work for teams we
are sitting here less than a month from
the start of the NFL Draft so we're
waiting for information just like the
rest of you guys are and we'll keep you
updated as soon as we get it last a
little bit of news before we get into
the rest of the show guys edie water
reported Thursday afternoon that dak
Prescott and the Cowboys are once again
negotiating that's good news
and good news for dak headwater from
ESPN says that he is about to become the
NFL's highest
paid player cha-ching for dak Prescott
and I think that's as should be Oh we've
talked about it a lot on the show before
if you're resigning and you're a Pro
Bowl level quarterback you should reset
the market and quarterback should reset
the market I mean I've even heard people
say quarterbacks you don't have their
own salary cap these guys make all the
money in the league they make most the
money for the league so that doesn't
surprise me and I think this is probably
coming out of dak Prescott scamp I know
Edward it's very tuned in there with
what the Cowboys are doing but he should
be at least for the time being the
highest paid player in the entire NFL it
just makes sense
yeah I think it's been quite evident
that dak understandably his camp is not
gonna take anything less and as we
always say on this show guys Pat mahomes
is gonna blow that number out of the
water
Yeah right after so I think it's a
waiting game right here where you know
for daca you're a quarterback you have
the leverage sit there and go hey I'm
not taking 33 mil you know give me
thirty five point five give me thirty
six whatever it's gonna be and I don't
know how you guys feel but I think my
homes will probably the guy that gets to
that forty mark yeah and I actually
looked because I didn't know and this is
just based on cap hit so not cash jarred
gulps cap hit for 2020 is thirty six
million dollars
that's his cap hit thirty not great
million how's that working out for you
not well not good good and the Cowboys
have other obstacles you know we talked
about it in the midweek show Travis
Frederick operand tires I still feel
like they did this in Missouri we have a
saying bass ackwards I feel like they
did this bass ackwards this because the
side Jaylon Smith great player needed to
do it they signed Zeke Elliott thought
he should have been the last guy to get
paid they paid Amari Cooper twenty
million dollars here and now you're
sitting here with your quarterback who's
a really good quarterback being the last
guy to get paid and I think it will get
done obviously but I don't think that's
the right way to make dak Prescott feel
like a valued member of the Dallas
Cowboys I'm saying your elapsed they're
bringing in a lot of veterans to like
you know McCoy and I I can't think the
guys off the top of my head but they're
spending spending more money than I
thought that they had this offseason and
they haven't signed dak yet I really did
think that would be one of the things
that happened I wasn't surprised with
Cooper re-signed but I thought
here DAC right after that like okay
we're okay we can go sign tomorrow
Cooper we have the plan ready for Dec
but they don't so this thing could drag
out for a while it is a little bizarre
out of all the players this is the one
they drew the line in the sand the
longest I mean you look at it and you go
I think we were all a little surprised
when they got Jaylon Smith done I think
we were all a little surprised as well
how much they caved to the Ezekiel
Elliott contract I mean that's a that's
a monster monster running back deal so I
think it is a little strange and I'm
curious to know what the real number is
that tax camp is asking for but that
this one out of all of them took the
longest yeah it is it will be it'd be
fun to see the number that gets reported
and then the real number after the fact
but hopefully DAC is asking for all the
guarantees that he can possibly get you
guys let's take a break when we come
back we're gonna have Jedrek wills on
the show and then we are going to start
our I guess what are we calling this a
segment on team big boards dream big
boards kind of for some of these teams
because we're all two of us are the end
of the first round but I didn't say at
the top of the show but I want to make
sure I sit in the first segment please
do your part stay home stay safe I'm
giving away Madden codes on Twitter to
encourage it there they're given some
away as well so if you don't know more
from me you can follow Madden on Twitter
they're giving away a ton of stuff to
try to encourage everybody stay home
stay safe and continue to take care of
each other and we're gonna do just that
right here when we come back talking to
Jedrek wheels until we are back I
promised you the best offensive tackle
in the 2020 draft class mister Jedrek
wills jr. from Alabama Jenn welcome just
Joe man thanks Megaforce and I want to
ask you right off the top dude a
question that has come up a lot while
evaluating your tape you played right
tackle for Alabama
Alex Leatherwood played a left tackle
would you play the left tackle if Toole
was right-handed muscle be more of a
preference to do the coast segment
I just always been a natural right
tackle and then we had outside the wood
was also a great play on a left side so
just kind of worked on each of our
favorites to be in the same position
that would grow a plant
yeah and looking forward to the NFL do
you think that you're versatile enough
you're gonna play left tackle or right
tackle I do this one that I've been
pricing on than this preacher process
leading up to April
and they kind of feel comfortable in
both and then I also feel like with the
right coaching and the right corners
I'll be able to do
Ricki don't remember to do I think it's
safe to say you played against the best
of the best and the SEC title games I
mean you name it Jedrek who is the
toughest guy that you blocked throughout
your college career right whole bunch of
guys even your last year being my
sophomore year but competition-wise man
I say probably the best friend was by
the Clemson front those who had multiple
first-round guys on there that we played
against last season the national
championship well this past he's not
privacy or Derrick brown from from
Auburn and just he's just a game record
and some that you had to be aware of it
at all points on the field
Jedrek you mentioned Clemson and that
that d-line was really good last year
what do you think of when you think of
Clemson do you feel like they're a
worthy competitor to Alabama being you
know the the top of the college football
dynasty right now or a little bit of a
pretender right no I do
spot last year something that we fell
short of that we that we let slip away
but they're definitely that people
forget about not being in like SC
conference they you forgot about a lot
of times but it's hard to go undefeated
anywhere and they proved herself to be a
national championship team having some
of those under their belt and at the
time being right now they have really
good steam coming back for next year so
I'm interested they can do in the
college football world I mean it's got
to kind of piss you off though right cuz
you said it they knocked you off their
spot but Alabama dominated for forever
so tell us how you really feel who's
your least favorite college football
team out there I mean definitely give
them credit credit where it's due but
they did not decide on West find
something that probably is it very often
that now we've ever country to this day
outside of the arrival aspect but then
they got a really good team and a
love-hate relationship I have friends
that on that team but like I was about
to play them you know just kind of like
all right now y'all my enemy saw it yep
with what's going on right now with the
coronavirus you know pandemic have you
been able to train the same way Jedrek
this last month or so um I have been to
an extent so I'm back home to Kentucky I
especially god I've been worthless in
high school and it's a good thing that
he has his own place that I'm kind of
getting work in what I need to in within
the with no legal rights of course how
difficult has that been I mean I know
you know like for quarterbacks they
they're having a hard time finding spots
where they can go and throw before an
offensive lineman where for some of you
guys maintaining weight can be a
struggle whether that's keeping on
weight or keeping your weight down is
that something that has been a little
bit of a challenge where you know like
you actually don't know you know when
rookie camp is gonna be where the TAS
are once you're drafted are you trying
to keep that in the back your mind yeah
most definitely but something a lot of
liming our problems with like you said
there's different sides to it there's
people that are trying to lose weight or
people to try to put on weight and
sometimes you don't have to keep in mind
at all times even being able to train
and find a place to Train and being back
at home having that nutrition that I
need on hand there's been something has
been in my favor I'm not really happy
with putting weight on losing it I'm
just a pretty pretty steady and constant
and what number is my goal I guess I'm
gonna say it that way but then this time
just kind of kind of stay where I'm at
gonna keep my body in shape for whenever
like you said whatever rookie camp is
gonna be now you're very familiar with
other tackles that are in this class
this is a historic offensive tackle
class you keeping tabs on many of these
dudes yeah do so a couple of husband
buddy so much like high school coming in
and out of camps and in front of those
guys kind of growing up my college
career being a highly touted recruit
mean you had a lot of options on the
table what was the Nick Saban recruiting
pitch to you that won you over my
college career that was a goal of mine
what's an asset what I would tell them
and receive it now so changed it my
freshman year and I just had faith in
Coach Saban his staff I knew that no
matter what year was gonna be here I was
gonna get the best coaching staff on
hand and somebody who was going to
develop me to be the best player I can
be you know the other day I wanted to
make the National Football League you
know be a great player in the next level
so I did a I feel like I made the right
decision that's where they got me to
beat if you want to win a national title
of Nick Saban's a pretty good guy to
latch on with but I want to know what
might be an uncomfortable question for
you
what is going through your mind when you
see to a get hit and you hear that
scream and then that moment of like oh
[ __ ] the carts coming out for for our
guy what's going through your head right
then then that was that was a horrible
moment very very home for everybody
Alabama country into and his family the
whole entire team that I was I was a
part of but like in the moment I didn't
even know that he was down like that I
using somebody's down here like her I
thought it was his ankle cuz he wouldn't
be playing in that that week that game
coming out of the LSU game he already
had some broth his ankle he played the
whole entire Jeannie can barely even
walk we had to protect our blood swab to
make sure that nobody got back and LSU
game and go to say that next week said
he felt good we're out in the first half
and played and then that happened it was
just heartbreaking she'd say something
like that happy to him especially
injures that he's battled through
throughout his college career yeah so
let's take it back further to that
locker room when tua and hurts were
still there and to it comes in to win
the national championship what was it
like that following season when they
were kinda I'll say air quotes competing
for that job with two great quarterbacks
in that locker room like a winning kind
of environment both of those guys just
come out day in and day out to prove
themselves it was something amazing that
I actually got to see right day in and
day out you just saw as close to
perfection could be those guys went on a
practice and just couldn't put anything
on the line that's better try to be the
QB one for the team now I know for a
bigger guy you can move have you gotten
in on any of these races yet with Henry
rugs Jerry Judy and Jalen Waddell at all
no I'm a special notice that's he
respect that he with those guys were you
there when they did the DBS first wide
receiver race I was they do like a
little like really yeah then they'll be
like you have to practice will be like
three of them going out it was it was a
day-in day-out thing that one's gonna
happen to come to sanity caught on video
have you ever seen anyone actually beat
Henry rugs in a race I have not I've
seen him in general tire though a lot of
people
I've been on I've been on Jalen waddle
for a while I remember going into last
chance I know rugs is fast but I think
waddles right up there too and a lot of
people even on Twitter like no no
waddles not off he's fast but he's not
up there but I've heard that too I don't
remember where it was that but that
waddle was right there that tied with
him so I wouldn't even be surprised if a
guy like waddle going into the draft
next year maybe even could outperform
rugs I'm excited to see we can do as
well he's fast and people see in a game
well I even when you lose off like that
at 12 pounds of gear it's the real deal
now you've blocked for some incredible
running backs already I mean we got Josh
Jacobs at the next level already tearing
it up Nagi Harris surprisingly goes back
to school you know were you surprised
that Nagi went back or you know how did
that decision take you know how are you
how did you take that decision um the
decision was clearly based up to him I'd
only have two inside on me yeah we're
going through our going through our own
kind of plus at the time it was
surprising means I thought he's probably
running back in the country there were
some guys with some better numbers out
there kudos like Dickie Dobbins Jonathan
Taylor Swift but I was expecting him to
come out but even going back to school
now so he's gonna improve a whole lot
more he's gonna put up some serious
numbers and just trying to be like the
workhorse for the backfield now we've
we've heard all the stories about how
well Nick Saban recruits guys to come
back you know we saw with leather wood
we saw an Aussie and we you know Dylan
Moses going back how hard was coach
savings pitch to get you to come back to
Alabama um he gave a great pitch but in
the day I feel like I just did what was
best for me and he also told Matty I
didn't make a horrible decision he does
gonna be a really good player I just
wrapped a top player in this draft and
he's just like I can't make decision for
you so wherever you're going with this
I'm support 20% and I'm either way you
can't make a bad decision and I have you
as the seventh best tackle on my big
board right now for this draft is that
about where you find yourself number one
spot and I'm just [ __ ] with you I got
your number one - I actually said you
can go back and listen to our shows
you're the best tackle prospect I've
evaluated
in a long time I think your athletic
ability sets you apart - so I just
wanted to [ __ ] with you a little bit I
got one more question here I mean Jedrek
sir just from watching your film I saw
you absolutely flattened Marlon Davidson
and open up a lane for a touchdown
against Auburn
are you trash-talking out there when
you're just you're clearing these guys
off the screen right now are you the
silent killer you're going to get so
okay I tell you to feel for my opponent
there's some guys that religiously
Hedlund there's some guys all your trash
talk so I'll do the dirty work and like
punish the face in the ground walk away
like you can hear my right in the back
you either they're like phone that's an
honest criminal not yelling at you from
the other side of the scrimmage -
Crimmins I'm just kind of like
straight-up ignore them and act like a
robot get some so bad who's the biggest
[ __ ] talker though that you faced yeah
oh say it do it you want to so anyone be
honest there's so many cuz I know they
get tired of I'm gonna door any player I
know they get tired it's a game in a
game out experience alright last
question that we got for you my man
could Alabama this team this last year
2019 turnt up tied to is healthy the
whole deal good Alabama beat an NFL team
be honest question so many time the guys
are from you are like radio shows or ESP
reporters no matter what it is like I
heard this question a lot below we've
talked about before like with my
teammates
of course we'll go out there and play
give % no matter what like I'm gonna go
out there I compete I never has been go
out there compete I got all faith to us
but I happened the day like he's got the
professionals but they do this for like
a job for living like just 12 your
veterans out there later in the day I
feel like it'd be a good game I'm not
gonna say they get blown up by like 30
I'm afraid that we can worry about the
day like those guys professionals that's
what they do so it's gonna be a hard
hard I could tell you that could you be
an XFL team oh I think you easily could
just be honest easily I feel like we can
give us give us an upper hand but I'm
anthem to dance the same thing those
guys are out there fighting for their
line I was like trying to go NFL roster
like
people who also played in the NFL got
pushed away for something like now
trying to gain it back those guys
offending them in the heat in the fire
before so another another one I'm I feel
like we have to go out there and work
for it for sure man it's gonna be it's
really fun watching you once once you
get drafted we're rooting for you
hopefully the world gets back to normal
and you can get to a camp soon and but
we will be man we'll be rooting for you
all along so try to enjoy your draft
process it's gonna be a unique one
you're gonna be you know you and your
draft draft class you gave me the only
people who go through one like this so
thanks for your time man stay safe out
there and we'll be looking forward to
seeing you play soon right yes sir thank
you yeah thanks man Thank You Jedrek yes
sir residual thank you again to Alabama
Cedric wills for hopping on the show but
now it is time for our team big boards
and we are kicking this off with our
favorite teams just to introduce you
guys to the format and what we're doing
here but we will move on to other teams
as we get into next week so we're
starting with the Niners for me Chiefs
for Melo Jets for Connor and what we're
doing basically is if we were general
managers for these teams
what would our big board look like our
top 10 players in this draft so this is
not the top 10 players who will be
available at 31 32 or 11 overall this is
how your board would actually look so
for the 49ers the top player on my board
would be Jeff Okuda putting him next to
Richard Sherman a corner be pretty damn
exciting I would please trade up somehow
and make this happen at show it became
for this then I went number 2 Jerry Judy
3 Henry rugs 4 cd lamp so the need a
wide receiver Emmanuel Sanders is a
saint
Deebo Samuel very good player we don't
know what we're getting out of jail in
heard yet so we need a wide receiver is
pretty significant feel pretty confident
you can get one of those at 13 number
five of my board CJ Henderson again the
need a corner I don't think it's been
talked about enough Richard Sherman is
very good killer weatherspoon is not
they need another corner in there number
six Javon Kinlaw my player cop for Javon
kinloss actually Ark Armstead so a very
easy natural fit in this 49ers defense
seven Justin Jefferson going back to
that wide receiver spot eight and a
player I actually think there's a good
chance they drafted this player sees our
Roux as the interior Evans alignment
from Michigan the need is there with
Western Rick Berg getting hurt likely
gonna miss most of this coming season
they already needed an upgraded guard
nine saviour mckinney that do it all
safety from alabama and then ten a
corner aj terrell from Clemson yeah and
I think one name obviously that you left
off was chase young but they don't
really need to fill that edge rusher
spot I mean D Ford still on the roster I
guess you know for now are you surprised
by that yes very
yeah when yeah all year like I they need
to probably let him go
and it his the way his contract was
structured was basically a one-year deal
so I I think I talked about it on the
show before divorce Buckner's my was my
favorite 49er the fact that they
basically chose to keep D Ford over him
as something that has really pissed me
off I mean they probably could have
gotten a second for D Ford instead of a
first for maybe I mean I played like 13%
of the snaps that's not an actual number
but it was low hey I was glad to see him
go so let's talk about my favorite team
the Kansas City Chiefs let's get it out
of the way here
and I'm looking at this that they're
picking at number 32 overall this Super
Bowl champs if you didn't know that I
think the number one guy on their board
has to be Isiah Simmons when you look at
everybody else I love Jeff Okuda I love
chase young in what they can do and
they're gonna be on my board as well but
Isiah Simmons could really play very
well in this defense all over the field
for them he can fill some needs at
linebacker if you come in play some
safety for him obviously and I just
think that if he's sitting there somehow
some way at number 32 overall he would
be the top guy on the Chiefs board
number two for me I'm going with Jeff
Okuda one of the best corners that I've
seen doing I mean what he's able to do
physically with his hands with his feet
everything he looks like the perfect
corner prospect so if again somehow he's
there they'll snatch him up chase young
I don't think edge rusher is a huge need
but if he's there
Chiefs will take him and then receiver
number four this is the fourth guy that
I just I don't think there's any way
that these guys fall to 32 but if Henry
rug's is there I think Andy Reed and
these guys are just gonna be drooling
over him they will find a partner for
Sammy Watkins probably move on from him
but I do think that Henry rug's is the
one receiver that have somehow found
himself who picked 32 the Chiefs would
pick him up so I've
stop you there because number one this
wouldn't be fair to have Tyree kill
Henry drugs and Miko Hartman on the same
offense I don't think the Chiefs
drafting a receiver at 32 is crazy
see I don't either and that's why Henry
rugs III put him on here because I do
think that if he you know got caught
doing something stupid with the
marijuana mask yeah yeah I think the
Chiefs would take him at 32 just because
he's such a weapon I we didn't really
think they would take a receiver last
year the second round and then guess
what things happen taking a receiver
number five for me though these are guys
that I think could maybe fall to 32 and
I'll start with CJ Henderson who is my
number two corner in this class I really
like him I think they're gonna see him
go in the mid-teens
I think teams like the Falcons are
probably gonna snatch him up before he
can fall that far but I would like to
see it number six that need at
linebacker is still pressing I like
Patrick Queen better than I like CJ
Henderson but they need a corner much
more than a linebacker but I would love
to see Patrick Queen fall along with
Kenneth Murray the needed linebackers
huge two great linebackers here if
they're there for some reason and I
think that one of these guys could
realistically fall to 32 just because
the positional need and whatever you
know the receivers that are gonna be
pushed up the board they've got to push
somebody down and then the last three
guys for me I think are in play at 32
overall I really like Jeff Gladney and
what he can do at corner I think he's a
plug-and-play guy that can come in right
away and help shut down a lot of these
good receivers that are in the AFC West
now along with Christian Fulton at LSU I
know that he's had some injuries he's
had some question marks but I think he's
a damn good player and I'd be very happy
to have him at 32 and last player on my
list is Cesar Ruiz the center out of
Michigan I really like his game I think
he's a great interior player I think
that he can get to that second level
he's going to make a difference on any
offensive line and him playing a sinner
and protecting Patrick mahomes for the
next five years would be something that
every Chiefs fan could dream about hard
to disagree with any of those all right
I'll kick it off here for the Jets
number one no surprise chase young the
Jets still do not have a pass rusher
chase young is very good he will not be
there when they pick number two another
guy that won't be there when they pick
Jeff Fukuda the Jets don't have much at
corner I know they signed Pierre to seer
hoping for a bounce-back season
Poole is back in the slot but it is
still a need here and I do think it's a
position group Joe Douglas will target
later in the draft number three and this
is the dream scenario for the Jets the
guy that was just on the show Jedrek
wills I think he does not make it to 11
if he does I don't know what the NFL is
doing I almost wonder guys if my number
3 player here Jedrek wills a number four
player Tristan Dwarfs are at play for a
jet straight up they have so many needs
it's hard to do that but man one of
these two guys would make a very big
difference on an offensive line that
needs a lot of help and the next guy as
well right here Andrew Thomas I mean
when you look at Andrew Thomas number
five on the board here he might make it
to 11 I think that would be a really
really big upgrade at left tackle for
the Jets if that happens if all the
tackles are gone you have CD lamb on the
board next and then Jerry Judy back to
back lamb and Judy the Jets lost Robbie
Anderson they need a wide receiver all
they have is Jameson Crowder I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you that Prashad
Perriman is the answer for Sam darn 'old
maybe he gives you you know a little
lightning in a bottle but this is a team
that needs a number one and a number to
wide receiver right now so if the
tackles are gone
CD lamb Jerry Judy Henry rugs all in a
row here and I go with lamb for the Jets
because he is a go up and win the
football kind of target for Sam's Arnold
I love Jerry Judy I love Henry rugs but
lambs physicality he has really really
good hands the Jets pass game was
miserable in the red zone last year
another thing that lamb would fix
he's an electric play maker after the
catch he can do so many different things
for this Jets offense where I understand
they need to take a left tackle with the
11th overall pick but if simply the
talent is not there lamb should be the
guy to boost this offense and the last
two players in this top ten are two
offensive tackles I just have them in a
different tier than the top three makai
Becton and Josh Jones they're very big
spectrum players low floors high
ceilings Becton especially the giant the
nimble giant good feet hasn't taken a
lot of real pass sets he just hasn't I'm
curious how he's gonna handle counter
moves at the next level so it's
interesting for me here guys as I made
this board for the Jets will they reach
at a tackle
like Beck Tanner Jones if the other
three are gone or will they take one of
the top three wide receivers yeah that
is the hard part I was uh I have a
seven-hour mock draft coming out next
week and I've started working on it and
I got to the Jets today and was like I
do wonder if everything they've done is
just setting up to surprise us because
they have added some offensive linemen I
don't think they've added many good ones
but they have added some it's true and
it does make you wonder if they could go
for a wide receiver at 11 or if like you
said if this is a team that will try to
trade up and you know maybe mortgage the
future a little bit to get a left tackle
in our two team something that has we
mentioned the Chiefs have five picks the
Niners have six and that's what I was
gonna ask hey do you realistically think
that the Niners stay at thirty-one
overall because I do I don't think the
Chiefs will stay at 32 I think that once
these corners start coming off the board
the Chiefs are gonna be a team that says
well might as well move back a couple
spots somebody can come up and get a
Jordan Love at 32 overall for that five
year last time they did that they trade
it out and got Chris Jones so there's
even like a press not bad like yeah not
a bad player like a team like the Colts
could move up and do a deal with them
for so yeah you want to get that pick
like yeah if you want to get in five
years mm-hmm for a quarterback that's
actually a really good idea Chris
Ballard just worked in Kansas City
yup knows Brett Veatch pretty well it's
a good idea Melo you should make that
happen I know just uh chief should hire
me or they should trade Chris Jones this
wasn't planned but I do want to ask what
are the Jets doing um sleeping
I mean honestly that's corn I think it
is full mic ins my conspiracy theory
here is truly that Joe Douglas has a
feeling Woody Johnson is going to fire
Adam GaSe in one year I have every
contract they've done has an out after
one year except the only good player
they signed Connor McGovern although I
don't care what anyone says the upside
that Prashad Pearman finish strong to
sear was hurt last year the one good
player is Connor McGovern and he's the
only one that has real guaranteed money
beyond one year
when Woody Johnson gets back from the UK
and it doesn't matter if Trump gets
reelected or not I'm pretty sure he's
coming back after the four year mark I
could see him kicking little brother
aside and saying you're higher did not
work out Joe Douglas is on a six-year
deal Adam GaSe is on a four-year deal I
think after the year if things do not go
really well this year Joe Douglas wanted
a clean slate for whoever new coach he
hires to have as much cap space as
possible
yeah the stroke I do agree that is a
very good theory the struggle with that
is gosh it feels like you need to helps
and Arnold you know I agree with you
completely that I think they are ruining
Sam Darnell so like Sam is good but he's
not as good as we thought he was gonna
be at this point and I I do think a lot
of that's the support staff around him
changing systems and things but
eventually you got to get an eval on
this guy before you pay him in two years
so gosh I mean I agree and for Sam I
mean I know he's been up and down but
when you look at it the USC staff he had
that was bad Jeremy Bates and then a
combination of Adam GaSe and Dowell
Loggins have been his coaches the last
couple of years and the bet he looked
the best under Bates which is shocking
really room it's remarkable with almost
no targets to throw to I mean no I mean
I I don't know if they're betting on
Chris Herndon to be healthy because
Sam's best games have been when
Herndon's on the field by far but it's
it is very interesting when you compare
and we've done this on the show
Josh Allen's supporting cast in year
three bacon Baker Mayfield's in year
three Lamar Jackson's in year two was
phenomenal with the line I just it's
it's not the way to help a young
quarterback who's still 22 by the way
Josh Rosen has a better supporting cast
right method saved Arkell does needs the
back yeah he doesn't take the